>>> THIS MORNING RUSSIA'S 36
HOUR CEASE-FIRE IS OVER.
ALTHOUGH IT NEVER REALLY BEGAN.
UKRAINE DISMISSED THE TRUCE AS A
CYNICAL PLOY AND THE SHELLING
INTENSIFIED AS MANY CIVILIANS
WERE FORCED TO OBSERVE ORTHODOX
CHRISTMAS IN COLD BASEMENTS
SEPARATED FROM FAMILY.
LET'S GO TO BEN WEDEMAN LIVE IN
UKRAINE WITH MORE FOR US THIS
MORNING.
BEN, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT IS THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: DON, OVER THE
WEEKEND, AS YOU SAID, UKRAINIANS
CELEBRATED ORTHODOX CHRISTMAS.
WE WERE IN THE EMBATTLED CITY OF
BAKHMUT AND WHAT WE SAW IS THE
FEW RESIDENTS LEFT IN THAT CITY
TRIED BUT DID NOT HAVE A VERY
MERRY CHRISTMAS.
THERE WAS NO PEACE, NO SILENCE
IN BAKHMUT ON THE EVE OF
ORTHODOX CHRISTMAS.
THE UNILATERAL RUSSIAN
CEASE-FIRE NEVER MATERIALIZED.
THE GUNS DIDN'T GO SILENCE.
AT ONE OF THE CITY'S SHELTERS
RESIDENTS GATHERED AROUND A
TABLE LAID WITH FOOD AND TOKENS
OF THE HOLIDAY.
AT THA
A VOLUNTEER TRIES TO RAISE
SPIRITS.
WE WISH YOU GOOD HEALTH, PEACE,
PROSPERITY, SHE TELLS THEM.
SHE KNOWS IT'S IMPORTANT TO PUT
ON A BRAVE FACE.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S RAINING AND
SNOWING OUTSIDE, I'M SMILING SHE
SAYS, I WISH PEOPLE A MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
I TRY TO SHOW THEM IT COMES FROM
MY SOUL.
SHE DID MANAGE TO BRING A SMILE
TO THE ONLY CHILD IN THE
SHELTER, 9-YEAR-OLD VLODYMIR AND
HIS WISH ON THIS DAY, I WANT
THIS WAR TO END AND ALL MY
FRIENDS TO RETURN HE SAYS.
FOR THE ADULTS THE GIFT UNDER
THIS TREE IS ELECTRICITY TO
CHARGE MOBILE PHONES AND A
WIRELESS ROUTER CONNECTED TO A
SATELLITE LINK UP, ALLOWING FOR
A TENUOUS CONNECTION TO LOVED
ONES.
TO REASSURE THEM HOWEVER THEY
CAN THAT THEY'RE STILL ALIVE,
NOT WELL.
AND HERE, THERE'S WARMTH IN A
CITY WHERE PUBLIC UTILITIES WERE
KNOCKED OUT MONTHS AGO.
YET IT'S HARD TO FEEL THE
HOLIDAY SPIRIT.
>> IT'S SO SAD.
SAD DAY.
>> Reporter: AS THE DAY
PROGRESSES, SNOW BEGINS TO FALL,
THE SHELLING CONTINUES.
CHRISTMAS EVE DINNER IS A
SUBDUED AFFAIR IN THIS BASEMENT,
HOME FOR NOW TO A FEW OF THE
DOCTORS STILL LEFT IN BAKHMUT.
GOD BLESS US WITH STRENGTH,
PATIENCE, AND ENDURANCE IS
DR. ELENA'S POST BUT HERE
STRENGTH HAS ITS LIMITS.
I FEEL PAIN SHE SAYS BECAUSE I
CAN'T BE WITH MY FAMILY.
I CAN'T SIT AT THE SAME TABLE
WITH MY MOTHER AND DAUGHTER.
CHRISTMAS MORNING AND NO LET UP
IN THE SHELLING.
FOR MONTHS RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE
TRIED TO TAKE THIS CITY BUT SO
FAR HAVE FAILED.
BUT IN THE PROCESS, ACCORDING TO
ONE LOCAL OFFICIAL, MORE THAN
60% OF BAKHMUT HAS BEEN
DESTROYED.
AT THE CHURCH OF ALL SAINTS,
PRIESTS HOLD MASS IN THE
RELATIVE SAFETY OF THE CRYPT.
CANDLES PROVIDE THE ONLY LIGHT
AND WARMTH IN THIS, THE DARKEST
OF TIMES.
AND WE'RE IN FRONT OF A HIGH
SCHOOL, WHERE IT WAS HIT JUST
MINUTES INTO MONDAY MORNING AT
THE SUPPOSED END OF THE RUSSIAN
CEASE-FIRE.
THE RUSSIANS CLAIMED 600
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS WERE KILLED
IN THE STRIKE, BUT WE'VE SEEN NO
EVIDENCE THERE'S ANY VORACITY TO
THAT RUSSIAN CLAIM, DON.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY IS PRAISING THE
RESISTANCE OF TWO EASTERN
CITIES, DESPITE THEIR NEAR
TOTAL DESTRUCTION.
AND HIS NIGHTLY ADDRESS ON
SUNDAY, MR. ZELENSKYY SAID
BAKHMUT AND SOLID ARE HOLDING
OUT AGAINST RUSSIAN ATTACKS.
DESPITE BEING AMONG QUOTE, THE
BLOODIEST PLACES ON THE
FRONTLINES.
ALSO ON SUNDAY, UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA EXCHANGED 100 PRISONERS
OF WAR.
50 FROM EACH SIDE.
THIS IS THE 36TH SUCH SWAP.
MEANTIME, UKRAINE IS DISMISSING
MOSCOW'S CLAIMS THAT A RUSSIAN
STRIKE KILLED HUNDREDS OF
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS IN
KRAMATORSK.
A CNN TEAM SAW NO INDICATION OF
MASSIVE CASUALTIES IN THE AREA.
AND OUR CNN CORRESPONDENT NINA
DOS SANTOS JOINS ME WITH MORE.
YOU KNOW, THIS SEEMS LIKE IT
COULD BE OBVIOUS RHETORICAL.
IF NOT ACTUAL RETALIATION FOR
THE UKRAINIANS STRIKE ON
MAKIIVKA.
WHICH CLAIMED MANY RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS LIVES.
BUT THERE ARE REASONS TO BE
SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THE RUSSIAN
ACCOUNT.
>> YES, NOT LEAST BECAUSE THE
NUMBER IS VERY.
LARGE SO THEY ORIGINALLY
CLAIMED THAT 600 UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS HAD BEEN KILLED.
AFTER TWO BUILDINGS THAT THEY
SAID THEY WERE USING AS
BARRACKS HAD BEEN HIT.
BUT ACTUALLY, IF YOU GO TO THE
SITE, WHICH A NUMBER OF
INDEPENDENT JOURNALISTS HAVE
DONE.
NOT LEAST REUTERS.
A WELL RESPECTED DAILY
NEWSPAPER.
AND INDEED CNN ALSO IS IN
KRAMATORSK.
DOESN'T APPEAR AS THOUGH THERE
IS ANY EVIDENCE OF A FEW
THINGS.
ONE, A LARGE NUMBER OF
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS HAVING USED
THESE BUILDINGS SUSPECTS.
TO, THERE APPEARS TO BE NO
CIVILIAN CASUALTIES OR MILITARY
CASUALTIES ON THE UKRAINIAN
SIDE.
AND THE CRATERS OF WHERE THESE
MISSILE ROCKETS HAVE LANDED.
ARE NOT ACTUALLY HITTING
BUILDINGS.
THEY ARE OUTSIDE OF BUILDINGS.
CREATIVE MISSED THE TARGETS.
AND INDEED, IT IS VERY UNCLEAR
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THESE
TARGETS A LARGE NUMBER OF
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS IN ADMITTING
THEM AT THE TIME.
THE QUESTION IS OBVIOUSLY, WHY
WOULD RUSSIA DO THIS.
WELL IT COULD WELL BE A
PROPAGANDA PLAY.
LARGELY BECAUSE THE INCIDENT
THAT YOU ARE REFERRING TO IN
MIKE EFFECT WHICH HAPPENED ON
NEW YEAR'S DAY, RUSSIA HAS NOW
ADMITTED THAT 89 OF THE
CONSCRIPTS, NOT SOLDIERS.
PROFESSIONAL SOLDIERS,
CONSCRIPTS HERE.
A VERY SENSITIVE ISSUE FOR
RUSSIANS A NARROW.
BECAUSE ORIGINALLY, SO SUPPOSED
TO BE A SPECIAL MILITARY
OPERATION.
I WOULD NOT HAVE NEEDED
CONSCRIPTS.
89 OF THEM.
WE NOW KNOW RUSSIA ADMITS HAVE
LOST THEIR LIVES.
REGIONALLY, RUSSIA'S MILITARY
BLAMED THEM FOR HAVING EXPOSED
THEIR POSITION.
THEY ARE SUPPOSEDLY USING THEIR
CELLS OR MOBILE PHONES.
UKRAINE HAS DISMISSED THAT.
BUT WE HAVE TO POINT OUT THAT
THERE HAS BEEN DISINFORMATION.
PERHAPS, OR CONFUSION ON EITHER
SIDE.
ORIGINALLY UKRAINE SAID THE
ATTACK AND WHAT YOU'VE GOT HAS
KILLED 400 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS.
RUSSIA ONLY ADMITS TO 89 OF
THEM.
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LARGE
NUMBERS ON EITHER SIDE.
AND, AGAIN A VERY CONFUSED
PICTURE.
WITH SOME OF THE CLAIMS NOW
HAVING BEEN DEBUNKED BY
INDEPENDENT MEDIA.
MANAGING TO MAKE ITS WAY TO
THESE DANGEROUS SITES.
>> YOU KNOW DOS SANTOS, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.